so I'm here on time today because I'm
doing the introduction some of you last
year may have remembered that I brought
two people here to talk last year about
improvement science and this is sort of
my little project to think about where
improvement science and informatics
intersect and how that might fit into
both our projects and our teaching or
our coursework depending on which side
you're on and so last year we had
someone from the improvement science
initiative and someone from Family
Practice who does a lot of work with
informatics so today we're lucky to have
Elizabeth Crabtree here Elizabeth is the
director of clinical integration and
evidence-based medicine here at OHSU
that's a new position as of almost two
years ago just shy of two years and she
came here from the Medical University of
South Carolina where she did something
similar and I'm not going to explain
what she does because she's going to and
she's also faculty here at de maiz and
has been working with us at the epc on
some of our national guidelines and
initiatives as well as with the work she
does here for Hsu so I'm going to turn
it over to her
great thank you well thank you so much
for having me as a net mentioned I work
as the director of clinical integration
evidence-based practice and then spend a
portion of my time in the Pacific
Northwest evidence-based Practice Center
and I came here from the Medical
University of South Carolina I also
spent some time at Texas Children's
Hospital and so for the last ten years
my primary focus really has been working
with interprofessional teams of
clinicians to develop and implement
guidelines at the Health System level
and to design systems of care that
essentially make it easier for
clinicians to do the right thing and
integrate research evidence into
practice so doesn't that mentioned I've
been here about two years I'm very
delighted to be at OHSU because as many
of you know OHSU is now forming
partnerships with community hospitals so
it's been a challenge and really
interesting to see how we can do this
work not just
within a hospital but across the health
system and then of course having access
to the tremendous resources within the
evidence-based Practice Center makes
this work really fun to partner and work
with clinicians who essentially author
national guidelines and are able to
speak to the evidence in such a clear
concise ways as made the job really
delightful it really appreciated being
here at OHSU I don't have any conflicts
of interest to disclose so I realized
that this slide might be a little bit
unnecessary given that the EPC is is
right upstairs but I recently presented
on ossu supplemental feeding guideline
in neonates at a breastfeeding
conference in Florida and I spent 30
minutes talking about our evidence-based
guidelines our process for developing
and implementing it and at the end of
the talk someone asked me to define
evidence-based practice so I thought I
would just lead with this going forward
but evidence-based practice as a field
is relatively new so the term
evidence-based medicine was first coined
in 1991 of course there's been a lot of
work to kind of lay the foundation for
it many years prior but Dave Sacketts
considered one of the fathers of
evidence-based medicine he's a Canadian
physician and he defined it as
delivering care that's based on the best
available evidence mediated by your
patient's values and preferences and
your clinical expertise and competence
so I think this this gets at the fact
that not all decisions are going to be
based on good evidence but the
expectation is that care should be
delivered based on the best available
evidence and that we should be really
transparent about the evidence
supporting this so I think we'll in
common misconception of evidence-based
practice is that it is just simply the
reflex application of data from
randomized control trials into patient
care when in fact I think it's really
much more complex than that
so of course evidence should guide our
decision-making but there are a number
of other factors that I think can
sharply influenced how a given piece of
evidence would be applied to a patient
in front of you and that really gets at
the point and I think a fundamental
tenet of evidence-based practice is that
care cannot be based on evidence alone
there are a number of other things that
as a clinician you need to be mindful of
your patients values and preferences
your competence and your skill as a
physician for our clinician for
providing a given treatment or
intervention and then of course we also
want to be mindful of costs issues and
resource constraints I think it's the
ability to look at the evidence and then
be mindful of all of these other
components which leads to what from an
evidence-based perspective is clinical
clinical expertise I thought this was
funny a physician said we have two
options either an evidence-based
treatment or an exciting risky
alternative but when I show this to a
friend of mine who's a psychiatrist
he's been practicing for about 30 years
he said you know Elizabeth I don't
really think that's funny because it
doesn't at all speak to their dilemma
that we as clinicians face we're not
often forced to pick between something
that's proven and effective and some
sort of obscure risky alternative
instead we're often given to sort of
partial sometimes conflicting sets of
information and we have to figure out
what to do and I thought you know that's
really what evidence-based practice can
provide is succinctly summarized clear
information that allows the clinician to
determine what to do with the patient
that they're that they're treating and I
think also highlights the fact that we
need to design systems of care that make
it easier for clinicians to have access
to that information and then also to act
on it so I think um there are a number
of drivers in our healthcare environment
that would indicate we need to as a
system figure out how to do this more
more effectively how how to effectively
integrate best research evidence at a
systemic level so data from dartmouth
atlas and the new england healthcare
Institute show that 30% of the nation's
healthcare spending is essentially waste
this is largely due to unwanted
irrational variations in care for the
last few decades payers both commercial
and government have been trying to
reduce this waste but have not been very
successful and then I think - especially
for academic health centers there's sort
of the expectation now that we're going
to have the capacity ability to manage
the health of a population of patients
and then lastly I think just the sheer
volume of information out there makes it
really challenging for any one clinician
to evaluate and translate all the
existing knowledge and information on
their own much less apply it which I
believe really highlights the need to do
this in a more systematic fashion
through the conduit of of an EHR so we
know that evidence-based practice leads
to higher quality care or better
outcomes can lead to reductions in costs
and also greater clinician satisfaction
which is why US News and World Report
and magnet and now required reporting
programs are becoming increasingly
interested and how clinicians and
systems deliver evidence-based care so
the question is how do we get there how
do we as a health system do this well
and effectively and I'm hopeful that
that's something that our department the
office of clinical integration
evidence-based practice can assist Oh H
s you with so we essentially exist to
support clinicians and providing high
quality evidence-based care and we do
this through sort of three different
mechanisms so the first is we develop
evidence-based guidelines at the local
Health System level where we allow for
clinicians to come together to sit
around the table and come to consensus
around how care should be delivered for
a population of patients coming to
consensus can be challenging but putting
something on paper really is the easier
part so where we really see the most
impact and where there really is the
most challenges when we start talking
about implementation so we provide
support for that as well so for all the
guidelines that are developed we
launched formal implementation teams
that are
see disciplinary and we do things like
work on enhancements to epic we do
patient and provider education sometimes
we may see that there's gaps between
what best evidence is and what our
resources are so that may lead to
proposals for programmatic development
and enhancement so it's really about
changing the behavior of clinicians but
also changing the behavior of the health
system and Howard how we're delivering
care and then lastly outcomes evaluation
is a really important portion of this
work so our content expert teams are
developing guidelines identify the
quality measures that they want to track
and monitor and work with our friends
and reporting to get that information
back to the content expert team to
figure out how to move forward to drive
for improvement so I feel like we've
been really fortunate to assemble a
highly competent and effective team and
they're all in the in the back we have
three program managers Marcy Hyder and
Tova Cole both are focused on guideline
development and we have a program
manager who's focused more is on
implementation were supported by a
medical librarian and then we have an
administrative assistants last research
assistant / guru of everything Kristin
camp who's tremendously tremendously
helpful to us in our group and that's
kind of the core component of the EBP
team within our department but we rely
really heavily on the content experts
that serve as guideline panel members to
really move this work forward and then
within clinical integration we also have
a number of program managers that are
focused more on piloting different
clinical models alternative payment
models things like that and we also
provide support for OSU's delegation
protocol program as well so when we
started doing this work two years ago we
realized that there there really wasn't
a group at OHSU that had oversight over
care standardization across the
continuum and throughout the enterprise
the pharmacy and therapeutics committee
at OHSU is a very
engaged a multidisciplinary group that
had done a lot of work around protocol
development but their scope was seemed
pretty narrow it was it was focused more
on on a pharmaceutical therapy um but
they have since revamped themselves
they've expanded membership and their
scope and they've made their name and
possibly long they're now the clinical
knowledge and therapeutics Executive
Committee but that's the
interdisciplinary governance body at
OHSU is responsible for reviewing and
approving protocols and guidelines at
the health are at the OHSU site level
and then at the OHSU Health System level
so when we talk about partnerships with
quality and adventists there's another
group it's the OHSU Health System
clinical integration committee and it's
comprised of membership is two physician
leads from each Hospital as well as the
chief nursing officer and then the CMO
from each site also supports the the
work and that's the group that really
responsible for targeting guidelines for
development as well as identifying
different content expert team members
from the various sites to serve on
guideline development team so I don't
really feel like this work would be
possible or nearly as meaningful without
this this governance structure and place
to support it so in terms of how our
guidelines are selected there are a
number of factors that we consider so we
look at costs and quality data we look
at local and national trends of the
guideline that we recently developed
around opioid prescribing for chronic
non-cancer pain that was largely in
response to just the public health
crisis that we're seeing across the US
but also here here in Oregon as well but
we recognize that clinicians really are
in the best position to identify what
the best opportunities are and where
there are gaps in quality so we solicit
input from clinicians any clinician
throughout the system throughout the
Health System can submit a request form
for a guideline and then it gets
prioritized so we've developed a
prioritization major
that the clinical integration committee
at that Oh Hsu health system level uses
to identify guidelines for development
and we look at things like sponsorship
and alignment so are we going to have
clinicians willing to sit at the table
from the various hospitals does it align
with a strategic organizational priority
what's the quality safety and patient
experience benefit that we anticipate
coming out of the effort is there a cost
savings or cost avoidance component that
we could look at does this impact a
population of patients that OHSU is that
financial risk for so that's another
thing that we take in to account when
we're selecting guidelines for
development what's the impact and
relative to the effort are there best
practices that we can draw from so are
there existing national guidelines that
we can pull from is there a PC or arc
report that is available to us or does
this impact a required reporting program
and then lastly but not certainly not
least important we also want to know the
impact this is going to have on provider
wellness and satisfaction because the
purpose of this work really is to make
it easier for doctors nurses clinicians
to do to do the right thing so here's a
snapshot of what our guideline
development process looks like so as I
mentioned we use multidisciplinary
clinical teams to do this work
ideally anyone that would have
interaction with a patient so any
discipline or specialty that would touch
the patient while they're here in the
hospital should have representation on
the committee and we also have a patient
or caregiver represented as well and
that content expert team is responsible
for defining the scope of the guideline
so the inclusion the exclusion criteria
the clinical questions that they won't
answer they're going inform the evidence
review and then the purpose of our group
really is to remove the burden of the
search in summation of the literature
from busy practicing clinicians so we'll
partner with a medical librarian we'll
do an exhaustive search of the
literature both for existing guidelines
and if necessary we'll look at primary
research studies as well we'll
critically appraise an animal
evidence will summarize it and then
we'll bring it back to our content
expert team who will bring their
clinical lens to looking at the data we
also have that patient voice there to
make practice recommendations and
consensus statements that really drive
the development of the guideline as I
mentioned our content expert teams also
identify the quality measures that they
want to track and monitor so that's
certainly a part of it as well and then
after we've got the guideline and go
through the approval process and we move
to implementation I'll just note that we
use the grade we kind of use a modified
version of grade it's sort of quick and
dirty grade because we're on a condensed
timeline so most of our guidelines are
developed over the course of about four
to nine months so we aren't always
necessarily doing a meta analysis
sometimes it's a little bit more of a
more more qualitative but we do use
grade as a way to assign a level of
evidence or a strength of strength of
evidence for those of you who maybe
aren't familiar with grade it's a really
nice tool developed by a group of
international guideline developers a lot
of medical societies that are doing
guideline development have moved to
grade because it allows you to assign an
overall quality rating to a group of
studies as opposed to just looking at a
single a single single study and then to
you to sign that a quality rating a very
low to high depending on type of studies
you have how closely they relate to your
question of interest in any study design
limitations that that may be may be
present for the kind of really neat
thing about it then is it allows you to
go step further and actually make a
practice recommendation so you'll make
either a strong or a weak practice
recommendation strong recommendation
meaning that the desirable effects
clearly outweigh the undesirable effects
or vice-versa if you make a strong
recommendation against something and
then a conditional recommendation is
where things are a little bit more
closely balanced so it allows you to
make a recommendation from a body of
literature be really transparent about
level of evidence associated with it and
as I mentioned we want to draw from
existing high quality guidelines but not
all guidelines are created equal there's
quite a bit of variability in their
quality so the tool that we use for
appraising guidelines came from an EPC
at the University of Pennsylvania it's a
mouthful too but it's they're
trustworthy guideline rating scale and
it looks at eight different domains and
allows for you to kind of get a sense of
how robust the methods were and putting
the guidelines together so then once we
have an approved guideline we move to
implementation and as I mentioned again
there's a separate team that's that's
formed its multidisciplinary and the
goal is to figure out how do we design
systems of care to make these
recommendations easy for clinicians to
follow so whether that be enhancement it
to epic or EHRs across the health system
or whether we need to educate and train
both patients and providers that's all
consider it as a part of a part of
implementation so we don't want to
reinvent the wheel as I mentioned one of
the great things about being here I know
Hsu is we have the Pacific Northwest
evidence-based Practice Center right
upstairs so there's a lot of great
material for us to draw from and we'll
start there but I think what's really
valuable about doing this at the local
level because often times I'm asked we
have national guidelines why why do we
even need to do this work is that going
through this process allows for
clinicians to get around the same table
and come to consensus around how they
want to deliver care and there's more by
and then just taking something off the
shelf so we'll look to national
guidelines first and then oftentimes
we're doing projects where there's not
great literature and evidence so we do
have to look at the primary literature
and then we also have the opportunities
through the guideline development
process to bring in local data so we're
able to look at OHS use own data and
then as I mentioned we have that patient
voice so it's kind of the marrying of
those different factors that lead to the
development of clinical practice
recommendations and I think there's I
think there's great value in that but
I think that the most valuable thing
that this work really contributes is
that translation piece so we're really
trying to design systems just to support
this whether that be with epic
enhancements like creating clinical
calculators or making revisions to order
sets and smart sets or changes in
documentation and flow sheet all that's
included as I mentioned we also talked
about patient and provider education and
then sometimes we see there's really a
gap between what's recommended and what
our resources are so this is an
opportunity to call that out and to
bring that to administration and say hey
we need more funding for medication
assisted treatment for our patients with
you know ope opioid use disorder etc I
just mentioned that because I have been
living and breathing opioid guideline
implementation since our EVP program
managers leading our implementation
efforts is now autumn eternity leave but
I think one common criticism that I
often hear of evidence-based practices
that is really cookie cutter medicine
taking away from clinicians the ability
to practice the art of medicine and I
would I would really argue the opposite
so I think the art of medicine really
lies in observation and being mindful of
what's happening around you and what's
happening with your patient and I feel
like what evidence-based practice does
is it gives you the most complete set of
information and then it's really up to
you as the provider to decide how care
should be given to the patient sitting
in front of you in the exam room so I
would argue that evidence-based
guidelines enhance your ability to
deliver medicine in an artful way while
removing complexity so these are
guidelines that we have worked on over
the last year and a half we have a site
specific to OHSU guidelines for cystic
fibrosis pain in is a pain and anxiety
management guideline for CF patients and
then the guidelines below that are all
it's all work that happened at the
Health System level so we currently have
guidelines first
opioid prescribing for Connacht on into
life pain as well as for supplemental
feeding in healthy term neonates these
guidelines are now in the implementation
phase we just completed a guideline for
colorectal cancer screening I'm actually
presenting it to the professional board
this afternoon and hopefully we'll have
an approved guideline and yield some
before with implementation this month
we've launched guidelines around heart
failure and acute low back pain and that
are hopeful of the next month to launch
guidelines for pancreatitis and dialysis
we have a website we're a little bit
buried on the o2 site but it's here and
all of our guidelines are available as
well as there's more information about
how to request a guideline more
information kind of just about the
guideline development process and some
of the other resources and tools that we
we provide I just wanted to quickly walk
through an example of our guideline
development and implementation process
and some of the outcomes that we've been
able to see so the first guideline that
we developed at OHSU was for CF patients
so as a pain in managing their pain and
anxiety and it's a very targeted narrow
focus and that was a little bit
deliberate we wanted to see how the
process would work before we launched
efforts on a larger scale and there's
also I think good reason for selecting
this guideline for development we have
noticed over the last couple years an
increased number of patients being
admitted with cystic fibrosis also those
patients are receiving more opioids then
in the past patients are also so we're
seeing messaging about opioids is highly
highly variable huge variations in care
that's being given and then our data
show that patients who are receiving
opioids have longer length of stays even
when you're accounting or adjusting for
disease severity and they're also more
likely to be readmitted so running this
kind of through our prioritization
matrix we had a highly engaged group of
clinicians that wanted to tackle this
yes there was sponsorship we felt like
this can really improve quality and
patient experience we did expect to see
a financial benefit because we
were hopeful that we would see a decline
in length of stay there are some best
practices that we could draw from so we
used the new guideline that came out
from the CDC in 2016 that Roger Tao
essentially he offers a systematic
review to inform it on opioid
prescribing and we felt like this could
this could enhance provider wellness and
satisfaction too so we formed a
guideline development team of over 20
clinicians from across Hsu is very
multidisciplinary we had representation
from nursing pulmonary Social Work
Hospital medicine Aarti pharmacy quality
management we had residents participate
in internal medicine
we had informatics at the table because
we're realizing that's a hugely
important part of what we're doing
especially as we're talking about
implementation and then it was supported
by our team so in terms of what we did
for implementation one of the big things
as we revised the Cystic Fibrosis
admission order set removing the option
for IV opioids and then delineating
different pain management options by
pain severity currently the previous
orders that listed the IV opioid options
first that that's what a provider would
see first when they were going into
order pain management medic meds and
then we did a lot of education presented
at Grand Rounds we went to faculty
meeting we had meetings with nurses
physical therapists RT we developed
posters and flyers and plastered them
all over
we also communicated via newsletter and
email and then we sent a letter to all
242 known CF patients at OHSU letting
them know about changes they could
expect in their opioid prescribing to
try to ease some of those difficult
conversations that they would have with
their their providers and we went
through one PDSA cycle and then we did a
feedback and some focus groups
and made some revisions based on the
feedback that we got from that our CS
admission order set the revisions went
live in March of this last year so
here's our data so our baseline period
is January 2016 through February 17 and
then you can see our three months data
and our six months post implementation
data and this is really hard to see I'm
sorry but this is showing order set
utilization so we saw in almost 10%
increase in order set utilization was
already pretty high with at about 87
percent and then it went up to 97
percent and 96 percent respectively so
this is looking at morphine milligram
equivalents per day per patient and we
saw an average decrease after
implementation of ten morphine milligram
equivalents per day that wasn't
statistically significant but we were
trending in the right direction and then
this is looking at length of stay so
after implementation or length of stay
went down by about half a day again not
statistically significant but when we
presented these findings to our content
expert team they felt like they were
clinically meaningful and and we're
excited about it so this is showing
inpatient length of stay by whether or
not the patient received an opioid and
here you can see that for patients on
opioids they experienced a length of
stay reduction of one point seven seven
days in the in the three-month data and
then 0.75 0.75 days from that in the in
the six-month six month period so again
not statistically significant but we're
feeling encouraged that those measures
are trending in in the right direction
and I think that as we get more patients
as through the ends we're pretty small
we'll hopefully see a statistically
significant difference but our
clinicians on the content expert team
where we're very encouraged by the data
so as I mentioned um we've often
encountered times when our evidence
doesn't match up with our resources so
with our CF guideline as well as our
opioid prescribing guys
we recommend non-opioid alternatives
including complementary and alternative
medicine therapies like acupuncture
massage but those are not readily
available on the inpatient side so one
of the things we're doing is trying to
address that gap so we've looked at
increasing access to non opioid pain
management for patients by determining
what therapies and services are offered
across Oh H s U and then also exploring
what services are covered by payers and
we're currently working on developing a
business case that would allow for
providers in the outpatient pain center
who provide those services to come up to
the inpatient floors and kind of be
designated resource so those services
would be available to impatience so I
think as we've done this over the last
year and a half we've learned a lot I
think some of the biggest opportunities
and lessons we've learned or we need to
include patients in the discussion so
we're CF guideline we did not have a
pain or excuse me a patient
representative and there's a very active
patient advisory group for CF and they
were extremely offended to not be
included so I think just highlights you
know the importance of getting that
voice and capturing that is a part of
the part of the process so for all of
our subsequent guidelines we we now have
a patient representative on our team
we're doing this across the health
system so we rely really heavily on
technology I'm horrible with technology
and so I'm just kind of allowing the
amount you know appropriate amount of
time to make sure that we're able to
connect and kind of troubleshoot all
those all those issues was something
that we discovered earlier on as well
and then engaging analytics and
reporting early on so I mentioned
they're a huge part of our
implementation work but we've also
started to include them as a part of
guideline development too because they
could kind of speak to what's feasible
in the system is we're thinking about
recommendations and how they might apply
here at
Oh Hsu and then just making sure that
we've got everybody everybody captures
it's great to have everyone engaged
early on as opposed to having to go back
and apologize for not capturing a voice
that was needed so um what's working I
think we've heard from clinicians they
really appreciate the interprofessional
dynamic of the work it's unusual to have
a table where you've got multiple
disciplines and specialties represented
and I think clinicians have really
appreciated that free food is always a
good thing so we try to schedule our
meetings over noon or in the morning and
provide breakfast or lunch and we always
have cookies the support from Andrew
Hamilton the medical librarian whose
word was our group has been tremendously
helpful and I think providers too are a
lot of people have asked like how do you
get doctors especially to do this work
and I think what they really appreciate
is knowing that this is going to go
somewhere so they're not just getting
together to put something on paper but
there's actually going to be systemic
support for translating this work into
workflow that'll impact their patients
and that that have gotten people really
really excited and I think also just
removing the burden of the search in
summation of the literature from folks
that are are really busy has has been
appreciated by clinicians as well so we
do a pre and a post guide lining
engagement in alignment survey with
every project that we do this is a quote
from an attending physician I think just
really speaks to the fact that we've got
wonderful engaged clinicians here at
OHSU who when they feel like their work
is actually going to translate into
something meaningful at the patient
bedside get really excited and get
highly motivated to participate so there
are a couple of other services that we
offer through our evidence-based
practice program one is an evidence
synthesis service so if there are groups
or committees within the hospital that
want to use evidence to
form the development of a policy or a
protocol and it's a more targeted
question we can do a pretty rapid
evidence brief with about a two to three
week turnaround and so here on the I
guess it would be your right you'll see
some of the evidence briefs that we've
prepared over the last year everything
from appropriate interval for diabetic
retinopathy screening to therapies and
for treating low libido and women to
continuing view for nor Fein in the
perioperative period and it's been
exciting to see how this work has led to
updates in policy and updates into how
our electronic medical record is built
as well so that's a service that's
available to anyone and a doe Hsu you
can reach out to us either through email
or you can submit a form on our website
and request this service and then we
also do an annual evidence based
practice course and the course is geared
at interprofessional teams of clinicians
this last fall we had nine teams
participate teams come to the course
with a clinical topic in mind and they
essentially develop a guideline over
eight one and a half hour session so
they learned how to search the
literature how to critically analyze and
appraise the evidence they're finding
and they use that to develop a
guidelines we had nine projects come out
of this year's course and was really fun
and we're able to use the course our
clinicians are able to use the course to
get continuing education credits as well
as maintenance certification part two
and four for physicians and we did
anticipate that clinicians participating
would also have the opportunity to get
some really nice scholarly products and
and work out of there out of their
efforts to that's just kind of a summary
of an overview of our department and
what we do I certainly welcome any
questions or thoughts and would love to
hear from you all
yes um thank you so much for your talk
this is a very interesting topic and I'm
personally very like enthusiastic about
applying evidence-based medicine as an
internist like as part of the fellowship
program I still find that guidelines
don't really are not available typically
at the point where they might be needed
where the question comes up was in the
guideline so and like the informatics
the EHR would be kind of the go-to place
so I I was wondering what are your
thoughts or your methods to when you
produce guidelines to make them computer
interpret all to some extent I know
there are some like Arden syntax or
glyph where theoretically guidelines
should be translatable so that they can
we actually automatically run against a
certain data but most guidelines that I
could find online are in PDF format
where I have not even a chance of really
using any NLP to work with them in a
more automated way yeah a great question
I welcome especially you all is
informatics informant in fermentations
I'm going to mess that turn them up your
thoughts on that but um one of the
things that we've done with
implementation is to try to design the
EHR in such a way that a doctor wouldn't
have to necessarily go and look up the
guideline it would be integrated into
their workflow so there that'd be
through changes in order sets or smart
says or flow sheets we do make all of
our guidelines available within the
actual order set so you can link to our
Hsu guidelines within the order set and
then also um results a panel and epic
under I think knowledge resources where
the guidelines are there within the epic
system yeah that's that's a good
question and welcome others thoughts and
ideas on that
Helia Abel thank you for your
presentation
so you said that you in both patients
also guideline developments
could you give one example maybe how
patients input affected your guidelines
what has changed
ah you taught that physicians are
satisfied with the process and the
results
did you ask patients if they satisfied
with the new care or you know example
from patients what do they see the
results yeah so the the Cystic Fibrosis
guideline is one of the only guidelines
that we've got data for right now we're
working on getting baseline data for
both our opioid prescribing guideline
and a supplemental feeding guideline but
that's a component of both those
guidelines is well actually for sip CF -
is patient satisfaction with their care
we found that it's challenging to get
that information because you're either
creating a separate survey or you're
using information that's gleaned from
just kind of the general patient
satisfaction survey that is sent out by
OHSU but i think that's going to be a
really important piece and it's
definitely something that I mean we've
listed it as a as a measure something
that we want to track and monitor but
would welcome ideas if you all have
thoughts on kind of the best way to do
that we've been struggling with it a
little bit to date and then in terms of
your first question about how the
process was different or how we saw
benefit from a patient expertise with
implementation with the opioid
prescribing guideline we've got two -
patient to chronic pain patients that
have been really helpful and helping us
sort through content information it's
available to patients so trying to
figure out and identify what they really
need and what kind of resources they
want and where that should be housed
their perspectives been really really
helpful to us and we've certainly
changed kind of our proposed plan for
patient education based on their
feedback yes
can you talk about the how the
governance of maintenance of the
material updated literature review
process is going to go as you scale up
to more clinical questions that also
have you been able to maximize the
literature reviews that you've done in
other ways to do they fall hand-in-hand
with requests for medical societies to
do evidence syntheses or is this just
built from the institutional's priority
as you specified on that one side yeah
it's a great good questions so most of
the most of our guidelines are selected
based on strategic organizational
priorities but that's not to say that we
don't think that they'd have value
outside of our organization so a lot of
the evidence briefs are now actually
being turned into publications and there
you know narrative reviews and
describing kind of the state of the
evidence and then also describing how we
have used that here at OHSU to change
policy and practice in terms of update
the updating process all of the
guidelines are updated every three years
or we are monitoring the literature to
see if there's any seminal studies that
come out that would indicate that we
need to make changes we're also looking
at regulatory requirements to see if
there's any measures that would come out
that would indicate that we need to pull
the team back together but in terms of
the update we look at the literature
that's come out in the last three years
we'll pull the original content expert
team back together and update the
guideline is necessary yes hey Dave door
how are you so I enjoyed this talk I
actually have answers for this one okay
that Rick Shipman came up with this
guideline and coding method I think Jim
he calls it it's not well documented
it's a little hard to find but it's
definitely worth looking at because it
is allow you to sort of encode the
guideline steps and then attach measures
to them and then monitor that sort of go
and see where things break down I don't
know if I'd wholly recommend it but
since you're interested you should look
into it so actually my question sort of
broad which is when you think about
putting the guidelines out and then
you're really trying to create behavior
change what uh you know what would you
change if you had a magic wand to make
that easier to do either in the EHR
through your educational efforts like
what would make it easier for you to
sort of take what you come up with and
put it in an implement it yeah that's a
really good question I think better ways
to communicate to get content and
information out to a wide range of
people would make a big would make a big
difference and then if our friends and I
tea could say yes to every proposed
optimization that would I would
certainly that would certainly make life
a little bit a little bit easier too but
yeah I think those are the two things as
communication seems really hard when
you're talking about this especially for
something like the opioid prescribing
guideline that effect affects such a
broad range of people strategies for
that can be helpful hi Ben or Walt I
know I think got passed you a little bit
about this before but what kind of and
and I think you guys have some of this
built into your guidelines but how are
you doing in terms of knowing whether
people are following them yeah so what
some of the process measures for
guidelines include things like order set
utilization but that doesn't always get
at whether or not care is being
delivered in an evidence-based manner
you could still be delivering
evidence-based care or not be using an
order set but that's kind of a proxy
measure that we
then I guess you know to just be able to
monitor some of the other process
measures that were looking at so was the
prescription drug monitoring program
checks before prescribing an opioid for
a supplemental feeding guideline was the
newborn weight loss tool used before or
during supplementation some of those
kind of process measures give sort of an
indication of whether or not a
guidelines being followed and then
doctored or kind of a follow up to on
your question and thinking about
implementation it'd be so much easier if
our health system and the reimbursement
models aligned with some of the changes
in systems of care that were were
hopeful to implement the fee-for-service
model is weakly challenging sometimes
I really like the criteria that you have
in place for kind of filtering out the
requests that come in so that it's not
just the loudest voice that's getting
your services two quick questions is
there a fee for your service and then
what is the percentage of like requests
that you're able to then follow through
with and develop guidelines yeah
um there's not a fee we're a free
service were funded by the hospitals
doing this work both for guidelines and
the evidence synthesis service and the
course there's no fee for any of those
services so because we're still early I
would say most all of the requests that
we've gotten we've been able to to
commit to or at least put in the queue
some of the work we're also trying to
figure out how we might be able to
fast-track the guideline development
process so if there are guidelines where
we topics where we know there's a really
good literature out there how can we
make this faster and streamline things a
little bit so we're looking at doing
that with sickle cell disease and I
think our heart failure guideline may
sort of follow kind of the same sort of
sort of process we're getting to the
point now where the demands are out
except far exceeding the capacity that
we have but today we've been able to
tackle most of the requests that we've
received yes I think it still alone um
so having worked on systematic reviews
and a scoping review and I'm sorry you
may have said this in the first few
minutes and I was like what how do you
just do two or three weeks look at the
evidence and summarize it so quickly you
must be some strategy for streamlining
yeah it's more like a rapid review sort
of methodology we're not doing formal
meta-analysis and pooling and don't know
dual review probably we do a review so
we do do a review of the abstracts as
well as the quality assessment but the
questions really are more targeted and
narrow and focus and we will work with
the clinicians to figure out what they
care most about and try to figure out
where we tend limit our
our results that we need to go through
so it might be we focus just on trials
or in systematic reviews kind of
depending on what the question is and
the volume of the literature
any other questions for those of you who
are in fellowship programs or who are
students what I'm interested in is how
much you think what you're learning here
applies to this and what do we need to
do differently this is part of our
thinking about how improvement science
and informatics overlaps anybody wants
to venture into that otherwise we'll
wrap things up so I don't have much of a
voice if you have ideas you know where I
am I think most of you do I'm upstairs
look at them and you know other people
around here who are thinking this Karen
and Vishnu and David all right well
thank you all for coming today
and if you have ideas of other related
topics or related people you'd like to
hear from let us know too here's my
email and our website but certainly when
welcome to opportunity connect with you
all around this as well I can hear what
you're doing and how we might be able to
support each other thanks for having me
[Applause]
what